[Music]
there are three critical communication
tools that every business leader needs
to be thinking about as he or she
communicates the first is to have
structure to what it is you say
structure is absolutely critical a
wonderful structure to think about is
the what so what now what structure this
structure helps you convey a point teach
people things in in some cases convince
them you first start with the what that
is the main point you're trying to get
across perhaps it's a new product you're
bringing to market perhaps it's a new
process you're trying to implement the
so what explains why it's important not
to you the communicator but to the
audience what's the value for them and
then the now what is what you want your
audience to do having that structure
helps you formalize your thoughts
package up your information and it helps
you as a communicator to be concise
the next tool you need to have is to
have variety in your communication and I
mean variety in many different ways
first you need to have variation in your
voice what we know is monotone speakers
are boring and disengaging so we need to
have some variation both in our rate and
in our volume second we need to have
variation in the evidence that we
provide whenever you make a claim make
an argument you need to support it many
people especially in the business world
use data data are critical and very
important and I encourage people to use
data especially if it's contextualized
if if you give it context but there are
other ways of supporting your claims use
stories use testimonials that's a third
party voice to find terms those are ways
that you can also vary supporting your
claims
the final tool I think every effective
business communicator needs to have is
the ability to paraphrase paraphrasing
is a tool that helps in so many contexts
for example if somebody is making an
argument or raising a question yet
they're very unclear and it's not for
sure what it is they need paraphrase say
something like what I think you're
asking is or the point I hear you making
is this that helps solidify for them
what it is they're saying and it gives
you a launching point for your response
similarly if you're in a meeting and
somebody is raising objections or
behaving rudely you can use a paraphrase
to say I hear what you're saying that's
something you're very passionate about
what I'd like to do next is so the
paraphrase is a polite way to move from
somebody else's communication to where
you need the communication to go with
these three tools being structured
having variation both in your voice and
in your evidence and using paraphrasing
you can be very effective in the many
different types of situations you find
yourself in
[Music]
you